so I know you'd sit in another interview
that like was it Richard Avedon and
different photographers were some of
your idols Francesco Scavullo I don't
know you just all the sort of these
fashion photographers so it seems like
that was your aim at one time to do that
or products and then well I want to when
I was going to photography school you
know you pick mentors if you're
fortunate enough to be motivated by own
in my case I had Richard Avedon I had
Pete Turner and I had you know school Oh
Annie Leibovitz
you know these are people I looked at as
being somebody I'd like to be like and
and when I finished going weaved in New
York and it became you know almost a
surprise to me to realize that well I
think I could make a living in LA I
don't need to live in New York you know
and I knew back then that lifestyle was
more important to me than money and I
did not want to you know leave my
families my friends so I came back to LA
and actually set up a business that way
because I'm sure the allure of doing a
Vogue cover you know especially when
you're just starting out is probably
well it's it's it's curious you say that
because as a photographer starting at
the beginning in my creative career you
know I did everything I did fashion I
did product shots I anything but a
wedding and and then you wake up one
morning and somebody gives you some
advice you know and that advice came at
a high price I paid a lot of money for
somebody to give me advice when I was in
my 20s on how to go to the next level
and the advice came with a question the
question was very simplistically you
know what makes you different from
everybody else and and he really screwed
with me because he did not want to tell
me what the simplistic answer was so I
tried everything oh I do great people
shots I built great sets I can motivate
children I can and then he said no no no
no no think about it and we'll talk next
week and I was terrified because I
thought how could I be so stupid these
give me a question about my own career
and then finally spit out I'm I'm a
problem-solver and the guy looks at me
and I look at him and he goes finally
you know and that's really you know kind
of encompasses everything about
creativity how do you you know make a
documentary
you got to solve the problem how do you
make a in my case I came across a great
idea for a TV show called the cleaner
based on personal experiences and how do
you sell it well you know you wake up
one morning you solve the problem you
know you got to figure out in our case
since I was half filmmaker half
photographer I started videotaping the
highlights with the person the real
person that the shows about it was the
first AMC drama that they made this is
way before Walking Dead and all this
other stuff and we were lucky enough to
have benjamin bratt as the star and the
character that he played on the TV show
was a gentleman that I knew in real life
so I filmed him multiple times talking
about what he did for a living and
condensed it into a 60 second piece and
that's how I sold the TV show and it
wasn't until you know six eight months
later when I'm working with the crew on
a pilot that they say do you know this
is like one in a million that you could
sell a show with no show success and
that's kind of the way I've run my whole
career is trying to focus on my goal
what is you know what is the the real
net choice that I'm gonna make am I
gonna make a movie about the circus or
I'm gonna make a movie about you know
somebody that goes out and saves people
from themselves and that's kind of why I
have a probably a portfolio visually of
different styles I'm always interested
in trying to grow well speaking of
growing so looking back on that mr.
Miyagi or whoever he was that were sort
of mentoring you do you ever think what
would have happened if you hadn't met
this person as frustrating as that
experience
a little bit it's this person defined
it's funny you can hire a psychologist
to come into your business they're
called business consultants they come in
they try to read your mind they try to
read what your goals are and they try to
help you understand how to get there and
the most basic thing is who are you you
know what do you really offer and it's
funny because as you listen to other
filmmakers talk listen other writers
talk you know it all comes down to one
thing and that is defining what your
goals are and Bethenny who's my producer
who brought in front of me a opportunity
to go to a a screenwriting fest in
Hollywood that producers and writers and
are able to to meet and actually get
pitched on one level it's a little bit
like one of those dating real-life
dating situations where they you got 30
seconds to meet three minutes to meet
somebody and then the bell goes off and
they switch it's identical to that but
each time they're pitching you their
movie and immediately I said to Bethenny
I said I don't want to take any pitches
for science fiction I don't want to take
any pitches you know for comedies I
don't want to take any pitch I want real
life stories and it helped define my
goal which is to find something that I
wanted to do rather than being inundated
with all these other forms and I'm not
critical of them it's just not what I
want to do
you